so you keep kicking a guy for three
years he's bound to kick back
well the whistle blow was very
inaccurate the conversation was perfect
it couldn't have been nice Adam Schiff
he's a low-life he should be forced to
resign he made up my conversation he
actually made it up it should be
criminal it should be treasonous we
don't call him shifty ship for nothing
he's a shifty dishonest guy and this guy
was negative when Mike Pompeo you know
there's an expression he couldn't carry
his blank strap I won't say they're a
disaster there to do nothing Democrats
99% of Nancy Pelosi sees time is spent
on this do you consider anyone who
opposes you Jem Zenith no I consider
when they lie when they stand before our
great body in our great chamber and they
make up a story that's fiction
like shifted he took that perfect
conversation I had with the Ukrainian
president and he made it into a total
lie it was a total fabrication and you
do admit that it was a total fabrication
yeah he's pissed and why the hell not
the media spends 36 months creating a
hurricane of hysteria then they rushed
to their fainting couches when he comes
out fighting sorry his reaction is real
and your outrage is not but if you're
still looking for proof of how the media
manipulates you news busters reveals
that networks devoted 7 hours to the
whistleblowers complaint while given
only 46 minutes to Hunter Biden's
sweetheart deal two allegations
one treated like Watergate the other
water under the bridge you think hunter
would become the hunt II make it fifty
grand a month for having the right dad
nope the media's brave firemen put that
story out as soon as they saw smoke of
course the media will say you can't
compare what hunter did to what Trump
did and they're right
corruption is actually worse than
talking about it you jackasses and you
just know the press is already working
overtime to dismiss this story about
Schiff getting the whistleblowers claim
first how will they preserve their
fever's fantasy maybe Adam can write it
for them so now you got an angry
president happily cultivated by a small
group of semi-literate
we're
in one marginal pseudo profession all
hoping to throw a country into crisis in
an era where everybody has jobs in
peaceful times and why they hate the guy
but it's also their business model
check out these circling vultures Trump
isn't magic he isn't invulnerable he
will you know if you cut him he'll still
bleed on this thing I don't know how
much simpler or CT er it can get this is
you know hookers in a whorehouse this is
Rudy Giuliani mopping up foreign policy
. well you know one of the I think
startling and delicious aspects of all
this is how quickly it's unraveling and
now he's been dumped in the middle of
this highway where there are cars
zipping past amid about 80 miles an hour
he doesn't know where to go if he steps
in the wrong way in the wrong direction
he's going to get hurt without division
there are no dividends and how can you
face your friends at the Hamptons if
you're not demonizing Trump better to be
cool than be correct country be damned